[Musique]
décorations pour le sapin ou la maison
produits du terroir et animations de
doute la recette est respectée pour ce
premier marché de noël avec un
ingrédient locale
plus de la moitié des exposants sont de
coignières nous avons dix huit exposants
dont huit professionnels et les autres
sont des gens de coignières qui sont là
aussi pour montrer leur créativité ya
vraiment de très belles choses aussi
bien au niveau tricot au niveau
décoration noël haut niveau je crois pas
des pis aussi voilà une première pour
beaucoup de ces artisans comme lionel
qui fait découvrir sa production de
pomme dessus amateurs vraiment de foot
qui est ancien et de pauses notamment
pour réaliser du cidre à l'origine c'est
vraiment une passion d'enfance c'est
l'occasion aujourd'hui avec ce marché de
noël de remettre au goût du jour ses
fruits anciens parce que c'est aussi un
verger conservatoire que j'ai créé que
nous avons également développé sur la
ville des idées pour les repas de fête
et aussi pour le père noël afin de
préparer leur liste les habitants ont
répondu présent à cette première édition
j'adorais les pommes là bas où l'on
fabriquait les jus les compotes de
pommes de poires
la chose a vraiment sympa très
intéressant sacré de l'ambiance ça
permet de rencontrer des gens
c'est vivant j'espère que ça se
reproduira
les butins ont encore du pain sur la
planche pour que tout soit prêt le 24
décembre et accueillir petit papa noël
quand il descendra du centre
[Musique]
de jouets par milliers